This episode was made possible by Wix.
And we'll tell you more about them later in the episode.
That's a stainless steel container that has plutonium oxide.
So hopefully that stuff will see its way onto some spacecraft in the mid 2020
timeframe.
Brady has been to really amazing lab where they're synthesizing
plutonium and they're making the plutonium to plow
spacecraft spacecraft that go to really distant places,
far too far from the sun to use solar sails.
So they need to use plutonium two, three eight,
which can generate heat through its radioactive decay and power.
The spacecraft the plutonium is made from neptunium.
The technical problem that has to be solved is that the neptunium
is supplied to the Oakridge lamp as a solution.
Okay?
So this is where we convert the neptunium liquid solution.
It's in a nitric acid solution and we can convert it to a solid that's,
a low concentration, and neptunium in that it gets to be a really,
really dark green whenever it's very concentrated, we'll put it into this unit,
pump it through a, essentially a rotary kill.
And that's in the other glove box on the other side.
And that converts the neptunium liquid solution to an oxide powder.
This is the automated pellet press right here.
It's going to first clean this dye out. It has to be really,
really clean before we use it.
Now it gets a little bit of lubricant and they'll come over and they'll sit in
the center of the glove box waiting for that solution to dry.
So it's just going to sit there for about 45 seconds or so. Yeah,
there you go. That's the funnel down. I'm just going to go pick up a vile.
So what's the,
in the violence picked up that's Neptuny monoxide and mixed with aluminum
powder. Now it takes off the cap.
Now it's going to dump down the powder into the funnel.
Now it's going to replace the cap on the vile and in a
second,
it'll take the vile back and put it back in to the position that it pulled it
out of. Now,
occasionally there's a little bit of powder that's left in the top of the
funnel.
So it's going to pick up a little tool and brush the powder into the dye.
That fat part of the unit is what we call the dye and then the punches on top.
And you'll see it put a punch into place shortly.
It's going to come over and gets rid of the funnel. First
punch is going to go sit inside.
Now it's going to pick up the whole unit and go put it underneath the press and
that'll start pressing.
And now they'll start the same operation again for another die and punch set.
When you sit here looking at this powder and what's being done here and knowing
that some of.
This stuff's going to end up in space, is that pretty cool?
It's pretty cool. Yeah, it's pretty cool.
It's pretty cool to be able to be part of the space program and be able to be
contributing material and knowing that this material will be used for decades to
come. The automated process almost seems very human.
Doesn't it like giving something,
a little shake and a little tap and the little habits that one might do in a
lab.
But I think the reason why the robot has been made to mimic a
human is because we know what a human would do.
And we know what works.
If you were trying to do some really sophisticated new
process, you'd have to do endless experiments to see whether it works or not.
But we know that the little brush of the funnel or tap is going to work.
So it's easier to automate that than to reinvent some new process.
Are we good at 52 press pellets? And it's in a little transfer device,
we call it a boat and that boat comes over and it sits in the center of this
unit, the actual pellets, those are actual pellets.
That's got the neptunium in it.
We've got four lasers that actually measure diameter and two different points on
the pallet.
Now it's just searching for the center of that pallet and just to vacuum device
to pick that up, it's measured the diameters. Now it goes, sets it down.
Now it's going to measure the length and approve.
So now it puts it into that cassette the pellets get put down in these
little holes and there's 53 holes around the perimeter on both the inside and
the outside that holds enough pellets for one target.
We unload those next door and we just drop the pellets down into the target.
That's the whole process of building a target. So for us,
the big deal with that we have here is the fact that we're going from making
about 40 to 50 targets a year to making it at least 200 a year in
annex.
And then eventually we'll get another line on the other side of the room and
we'll be making around 400 targets a year in order to make the production we
need for, to supply NASA. They want more and more.
And actually we think that going into the latter part of the next decade,
we'll probably be asked to increase our production,
but that's something that we're, we talked to NASA about on a routine basis.
So it's, it's a, it's a program where you got to plan for the next 10 years.
You can't discipline what you're going to do tomorrow,
because by that time it's too late, you can't do anything about it.
Okay? Now we're going to, what we call is the control room.
This is where we have heavily shielded hot cells.
And that's how we work on the, um,
irradiated targets safely so that we can say,
we make the plutonium and give that again, give it some NASA.
Your ELA, minium, and Neptunian oxide spins.
It's 50 days baking and nutrients. You've made a whole bunch of new plutonium,
but you've also made a lot of other stuff. We don't.
Want a lot of fishing products. And this is what you do. The chemistry. Yeah.
This is where we do the chemistry.
The radiation dose is just too high to handle in anything but a heavily shielded
hot cell. This is four and a half feet of shielding.
It's a combination of led glass and mineral oil led glass to shield from the
Gamma's intense gamma source.
And the mineral oil is used to shield for neutrons.
Yeah, yeah, no, yeah. That's liquid. Yeah. So if I punched a hole in that.
Which I can't do a whole bunch of oil would mention the oil would come out.
Yeah. Yeah.
All this equipment in here is used for the processing chemical processing.
We have a dissolver the top of it is in the floor of that cubicle and you see
all the pipes coming off of it. So that's why we call dissolver.
There's actually a,
an opening it's about say four to five inches in diameter that we take our
targets and those are lowered into the dissolver we'll do about 20 or
30 targets at a time and dissolve the aluminum. And so using a,
a sodium hydroxide solution. And then once we dissolved all the aluminum,
we decamped that and get rid of all the liquid waste.
And then we come back and hit the actinides with concentrated nitric acid
concentrate, nitric acid will dissolve the actinides.
And that allows us to start doing the chemical processing to separate the
plutonium and the neptunium from the fission products.
Have we got some targets in there that we could take a look at? Fortunately,
these guys do this. Yeah. So what we've got over,
there is some targets that we use during our experimental program.
That's an actual target that we use. If we were planning on processing it,
we cut off the top and the bottom because the top four inches and the bottom
four inches are just aluminum. And what we want is the, uh,
neptunium oxide and plutonium oxide. That's in the center of that target.
So we'd actually cut off the top and bottom and then put about 20 to 30 targets
inside the dissolver and then pump the liquid sodium hydroxide in to start the
dissolution process.
So each one of those targets is going to give us just under four grams of
plutonium oxide as a product we have to run through around 400 of those a
year in order to make enough material.
One thing that's kind of cool about the Neptune plutonium is they'll turn
certain colors.
So if you see a color exiting in the right way,
you're pretty confident that it's working, right? So if see,
in dark green going out, your neptunium is going out.
If you see kind of a purple-ish or magenta color coming this other way,
you got your plutonium. So it's, you can visually kind of see what's going on,
which is kind of cool.
Then we have a lot of ways we actually measure those concentrations to get very
precise results.
What do you think when you see these people that have to work with something
that's just so dangerous? Like, does it give you chills? Well,
I found it exciting. Of course, although the material is dangerous,
it's so well protected or they're well protected from them.
It isn't dangerous, but you always wonder what would go wrong.
And I think it's a really good lesson to us chemists about how you can do
really quite dangerous experiments.
If you take the right precautions and have the right equipment accidents happen
in chemistry, when you use the wrong equipment or you don't take precautions.
Bob, where are you? You haven't. I have no. Did you use to do it or is it never,
never tried? I, I, my first chemistry experiment in a lab, I,
we were doing a very complex separation and I had it in a
little bottle. And then as I was moving around a,
dumped the bottle on the ground and had to try to sweep it all up and I didn't
get a very high grade on that test, that, that experiment now that was not,
yeah. I leave it to the experts. Yeah.
Can't believe how like gentle you can be with that thing.
That's a stainless steel container that has plutonium oxide made in
what we call our campaign three, which we did last spring.
And so this material is going to be held in self until we get the capability to
be able to ship it out to Los Alamos.
So hopefully that stuff will see its way onto some spacecraft in the mid 2020
timeframe.
I really liked how our guide was so excited
and pleased that he was participating albeit indirectly
in the space mission.
And I think it really demonstrates how,
even in really weird technological events
like spacecraft going to Pluto underneath and backing
it all is a chemist. Yeah.
This video was supported by Wix,
which also happens to be who we've used to make this new periodic videos
website, pretty nifty. Hey,
and here's a little sneak peek under the hood where we've used weeks to design,
make changes, get things looking just right.
I have to say I've been really impressed by just how much control you have over
a Wix site. Sure. They have some templates to get,
you started lots of templates actually, but there's no detail.
You can't find tune and tweak to get it just how you want it.
No little bell or whistle.
You can't add to get your site doing what you want it to do.
Just imagine what the periodic table might've looked like.
If Dmitri Mendeleev had used Wix now to check them out yourself,
go to wix.com/go/periodic videos.
There's the address on the screen?
wix.com/go/periodic videos and our thanks to
Wix for supporting this episode.
And we convert about 10%.
Of that. Neptunium two 37 to platonic.
38.